[Music]
interesting article out there right now
the share of American young adults
living with their parents is the highest
in 75 years parents in the US can not
get rid of their kids the share of young
adults in their late 20s living with
their parents is the highest in 75 years
according to a recent study Pew Research
33 percent 1 and 3 25 to 29 year olds
live with their parents or grandparents
three times as many as in 1970 so here
let me help you with this mom and dad I
am an eagle that doesn't leave the nest
is what's known as a turkey you are not
blessing your children by supporting
them when they're over twenty five years
old now could mom and dad be a safety
net yes but a hammock is ridiculous
there's a difference between a hammock
and a safety net and this these
statistics indicate hammock so I will
tell you as the proud father of three
productive young adults married to three
productive young adults all older than
25 that that it does them great good
emotionally and spiritually when they
leave home when they have to buy their
own food and cook it or go to a
restaurant and get some it's good for
them when they have to pay their own
electric bill it is good for them when
they have to pay their own freakin rent
it is good for them now I'm not talking
about someone being homeless or having a
health problem or coming out an abusive
divorce and they need to come home and
heal for a little while that's not
that's a safety net and all of that is
fine I would never tell you to not love
your children and care for them I care
for my children one of my children has a
serious problem I've got a big old house
they can come there for a while but I do
not want to be there serious problem
I want to be the solution to their
serious problem which is a safety net
not a hammock you are being in a blurs
or and the problem is you have one third
of the people in their 20s that are
emotionally stunted as what we're saying
they have not developed into full-grown
emotional adults and let me just tell
you if you're offended by that because
you're 26 and you live in your mom's
basement good I'm talking to you my goal
here is to piss you off
be a man be a woman grow a backbone walk
out there and be somebody it's good for
you you will have dignity that you do
not have in mommy's basement fold your
own freakin underwear or don't but it's
your underwear your mommy shouldn't be
washing it when you're freaking 27 years
old it's it's absurd you guys now again
I will distinguish one more time before
I start getting all this idiot hate mail
from some of you people you don't like
Millennials I love Millennials I've got
a whole bunch of 24 to 29 year olds
working here that are absolutely
excellent young people absolute
incredible some of the best workforce
I've ever seen in my life are the
Millennials the good ones the bad ones
you can't pry the participation trophy
out of their little fingers and they're
sitting around waiting on someone to
affirm them well you don't you don't get
affirmed when you don't do nothing
there's a reason we respect the winner
and give them a trophies because they
did something the loser didn't do I've
won some I've lost some you've won some
you've lost some get up off your butt
and get out of mommy's basement come on
dad's where are you I'm not suggesting
you need to be mean to your children
unkind to your children nasty with your
children or anything like that but I'm
just telling you you're a straight-up
codependent and a blur when you have a
27 year old living in the basement
because he won't go get a job in an
economy that's white-hot and there's a
labor shortage in most areas right now
you can get construction work if you can
walk out the back door in almost any
city in America right now oh it's hard
work yeah I noticed that I've done it
and you know what working a hard
back-breaking work will do and make you
read a book so you don't do hardback and
brick hard-working pack breaking work
the rest of your life you know and maybe
you can even learn to say it this is
absurd you guys 33 percent that means if
you line up all the 25 to 29 year olds
in a row one-third of them are at home
some percentage of that is to well they
have does the crippling student loan
debt yeah they call in here every day
having overcome their crippling student
loan debt they stand here in our lobby
and do debt free screams having
overcoming but they didn't the overcome
it because they were mommy's basement
they were kind of because they took six
jobs gonna work their tail end off and
quit sitting around whining about how
entitled they are for the for the
culture to take care of them and the
reason they think there that the reason
they're entitled like that is because
they sit in your basement you're not
doing your kids a favor now our kids
came out of college one was married by
the time she got out of college which I
never thought would happen but worked
out perfect one never moved into our
house moved straight into a rental and
one moved into our house for about three
months until they got the roommates
lined up and the other stuff so after
college I have a total between three
kids of three months of them being with
us again if something had happened and
there was a health problem or a a
dramatic economic problem laziness is
not a dramatic economic problem by the
way a dramatic economic problem if
there's something along those lines
then we would have said okay you can
stay here until you get you know get
your feet under you but we're not gonna
sit here and enable you to know I can't
find a job well you haven't left the
front of the Nintendo of course you
can't find a job you're sitting there
looking at the stupid TV you're watching
all those HBO channel
I pay for this has got to stop you guys
the this boomerang generation they call
it they leave and then they come back
you throw them out and they come back
that's what a boomerang does and it is
damaging the economics of our culture it
is damaging their spiritual walk
they have no dignity you are not doing
them a favor well they're not bothering
ya you're not doing them a favor they're
soft again you don't have to be some
kind of tough guy or mean or nasty
I was never unkind to my heart our
children as they were leaving they
didn't leave because they had a toxic
situation at home they left because they
wanted to have the dignity of being an
adult you cannot do that in mommy's
basement you can't now I talk to people
on the air here they're 32 years old and
went through an abusive marriage and
there they've come back home and they've
got a little baby and they're trying to
get their feet back under them a single
mom hey do that take care of them love
them well for a period of time but if
they come back home in their thirty to
an abusive marriage and have a little
baby by the time they're 37 they should
be gone again even in that situation
it's a safety net it's not a hammock any
turkey that doesn't leave than any Eagle
that doesn't leave the nest is
eventually known as a turkey look it up
this is why you teach children how to
handle money so they have some that's
why we wrote the book smart money smart
kids how to teach your kids how to
handle money so they leave this is the
Dave Ramsey show